Bonjour, je m'appelle Katy Beslado.
Je suis directrice de la stratégie IBM Quantum
et de la recherche appliquée. Je suis ici pour démystifier
le plus d'idées reçues sur l'informatique quantique
possible en soixante secondes.
L'informatique quantique, c'est absolument réel.
Nous avons des appareils sur le cloud IBM auxquels tout le monde peut accéder.
Oui, mais uniquement pour certaines tâches où ils excellent vraiment,
des maths ultra-complexes comme celles qui régissent l'univers.
Mais si tu veux faire des tableurs ou envoyer des e-mails, utilise
ton PC.
Oui, en théorie, mais pas
avant longtemps. Personne ne fabrique encore un ordinateur assez puissant pour ça.
Pour l'avenir prévisible, nous sommes sur la bonne voie,
et quand on y arrivera, on va changer la façon dont on protège
l'information.
C'est complètement faux. Les ordinateurs quantiques
sont fondamentalement différents
et utilisent les lois de la nature pour traiter l'information.
L'IA d'aujourd'hui tourne sur de bons vieux appareils classiques,
mais on croit qu'ils travailleront ensemble à l'avenir.
Ce n'est pas vrai. Nous avons un écosystème formidable
de start-ups, d'universités, de laboratoires nationaux et de partenaires industriels qui
utilisent nos appareils tous les jours.
Non, l'informatique inspirée du quantique existe
depuis longtemps et tourne sur des appareils classiques. Elle
ne tiendra jamais la promesse de l'informatique quantique.
Si tu veux du vrai quantique, tu dois le faire avec de vrais ordinateurs quantiques,
de vrais ordinateurs quantiques.